el vídeo de hoy ha sido posible gracias
a masterworks
hay una palabra que seguro no dejas de
oír en los últimos meses inflación los
bancos centrales están imprimiendo
dinero como si no hubiera mañana what
ever takes lo que por ejemplo ha
provocado en enero del 2022 un aumento
interanual del 7% en los precios de eeuu
los niveles más altos en 39 años hasta
ahora para cubrirse contra la inflación
lo habitual era invertir en oro en
acciones o incluso en inmuebles pero
existen nuevas alternativas y queremos
enseñarnos una super interesante el
mercado del arte el mercado del arte es
gigantesco se estima que el total de
activos ronda los 17 billones de dólares
y deloitte calcula que puede crecer
otros 900 mil millones para 2026 además
como podéis ver en pantalla su
rentabilidad no ha sido nada desdeñable
de hecho entre las grandes fortunas es
una apuesta muy habitual ahí está el
caso de la familia rockefeller que a lo
largo de los años fue acumulando una de
las mayores colecciones
de obras de arte de la historia que se
vendieron en 2018 por una astronómica
cifra de
835 millones de dólares vale seguro que
estés pensando pero a ver chicos a mí
esto qué narices me importa cómo voy a
diversificar mi cartera con una obra de
basquiat o de warhol que cuestan
millones de dólares eso está totalmente
fuera de mis posibilidades eso sólo
pueden hacerlo los billonarios bueno
puedes esperar porque aquí es donde
entra masterworks masterworks tiene como
misión que cualquier persona puede
invertir en grandes obras de arte a
través de pequeñas participaciones con
masterworks puede ser copropietario de
piezas de arte exclusivas que
contribuyan a cuidarte de la inflación y
ojo incluso quién sabe poder llegar a
obtener una buena rentabilidad por
ejemplo los inversores que compraron la
monalisa de banks y con masterworks
consiguieron un rendimiento anualizado
del 32 por ciento estaremos acaso ante
una nueva forma de inversión alternativa
para diversificar y optimizar nuestras
carteras os dejamos un link a
masterworks abajo en la descripción
accediendo a través de este link podréis
saltarnos la lista para registrarlos y
como siempre en todo lo relacionado con
la inversión mucha cabeza no existen
nada libre de riesgos y ahora sí
empecemos con nuestro vídeo de hoy
[Música]
os lanzó una pregunta alguna vez os
habéis preguntado si a europa le
conviene más tener la protección militar
de la otan o crear en cambio su propio
ejército europeo sí ya sé que pueden ser
cuestiones compatibles pero si tuvierais
que escoger por cuál de las dos opciones
os decantaría y en este vídeo nos vamos
a ocupar de un tema con importantes
implicaciones especialmente si tenemos
en cuenta los recientes acontecimientos
en la frontera entre polonia y
bielorrusia y sobre todo la crisis
político-militar entre ucrania y rusia
una frontera donde las fuerzas rusas han
pasado meses haciendo más y más cálculos
sobre una posible invasión una invasión
que si bien no implica en absoluto a
ningún país de la otan es vista por
muchos expertos en seguridad así como
por los propios países bálticos como la
antesala el ensayo de lo que un buen día
podría llegar a suceder por ejemplo en
estonia letonia o lituania así que
teniendo todo esto en cuenta os apetece
saber más sobre la defensa de europa que
le conviene más a los miembros de la
unión europea la otan o un nuevo
ejército europeo desarrollado con al
margen de eeuu cuál de las dos opciones
garantiza mejor los intereses y la
seguridad de los países comunitarios
pues bien respondamos a todas estas
preguntas atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
como se puede garantizar la seguridad de
europa esta es la pregunta pero antes de
que empecemos a meternos de lleno en la
cuestión de si otan si votan no ejército
europeo sí o ejército europeo no veamos
brevemente que es exactamente la otan y
en qué consiste porque es seguro seguro
que la inmensa mayoría de vosotros lo
sabéis pero puede que alguno veáis toda
esta cuestión con cierta distancia
[Música]
la otan la organización del tratado del
atlántico norte es una organización
militar internacional cuyo objetivo pasa
por garantizar la defensa colectiva de
los países miembros fue creada en 1949
en las fases iniciales de la guerra fría
y el enfrentamiento a cara de perro
entre occidente y la unión soviética en
aquel momento y durante las cuatro
décadas posteriores la amenaza de
terminar en guerra o de sufrir un ataque
soviético sobre la europa occidental era
muy real pero precisamente por eso se
decidió que la única manera de disuadir
al enemigo era unir fuerzas entre los
países europeos pro occidente yo eeuu la
clave básica de este modelo es que si
algún enemigo ataca a cualquiera de los
países miembros de la otan el resto se
compromete en asistirles militarmente
prestarles ayuda e incluso intervenir
directamente un modelo que ha
sobrevivido en el tiempo pero que ha
visto cambiar el nombre de su principal
adversario de la unión soviética a rusia
ahora bien no se trata solo de un
compromiso de defensa mutua la otan
también busca mejorar la modernización
la coordinación y la integración de los
diferentes ejércitos para llegado el
caso poder luchar juntos hablamos de un
paraguas de seguridad completo toma de
decisiones asunción de compromisos e
incluso despliegue de tropas para
reforzar la seguridad de los aliados más
débiles esto es por ejemplo lo que
ocurre con las fuerzas que muchos países
miembros de esta alianza envían a los
países bálticos también podríamos
englobar aquí los despliegues
permanentes o rotatorios de fuerzas de
eeuu en países miembros de la alianza en
términos de seguridad son había en
verdad integración coordinación y el
apoyo de la mayor superpotencia del
mundo si hablamos de seguridad que más
se puede pedir
[Música]
pues sin embargo amigos hay un pequeño
problema con el paso de los años la otan
parece haberse hecho menos popular entre
las viejas potencias de la europa
occidental por ejemplo prestar mucha
atención a estas declaraciones del
presidente francés sobre la crisis con
rusia bueno que los europeos y los eeuu
se coordinen pero es necesario que los
europeos lleven a cabo su propio diálogo
emanuel macrón presidente de francia
ante el parlamento europeo si lo habéis
escuchado bien básicamente lo que
marcará un pibe es que la política de
seguridad de europa sea completamente
independiente a la de eeuu que a
bruselas lleve a cabo sus negociaciones
acuerdos y compromisos de forma
completamente independiente a washington
incluso en casos de conflicto lo que si
nos paramos a pensarlo supone romper el
frente común el eje atlántico la idea
que subyace a la propia otan
y evidentemente para poder ser
independiente en materia de seguridad
necesitas tener tus propias capacidades
militares claro digo yo no vas a querer
tomar tú las decisiones mientras te
cubres con los soldados de otros
queridos amigos amigas no es en absoluto
frecuente que un líder europeo con tanto
peso
hable con semejante grado de otan
escepticismo de hecho escuchando macrón
casi podríamos llegar a pensar no sé que
vladimir putin estuvo a punto de salirse
con la suya fracturar la otan a golpe de
amenazas por cierto si queréis saber más
detalles sobre cómo ha ido cambiando la
otan con el paso del tiempo y sobre cómo
funciona no os podéis perder este vídeo
[Música]
os dejamos el enlace abajo en la
descripción
[Música]
a ver os habéis preguntado alguna vez
cómo es la defensa de europa el sistema
actual y qué papel juega a eeuu en ella
pues bien los ejércitos pertenecientes a
la otan cuentan con cientos y cientos de
miles de soldados en la vieja europa por
supuesto la inmensa mayor parte de ellos
pertenecen lógicamente a los propios
países europeos hablamos sin embargo de
ejércitos que suelen tener muchísimas
carencias particularmente si nos
referimos a sus capacidades de
despliegue algo que limita mucho su
operativa
[Música]
y esto esto no lo decimos nosotros sino
la propia unión europea en su borrador
para crear una fuerza militar europea de
respuesta rápida necesitamos ser capaces
de responder a amenazas inminentes o
reaccionar rápido a situaciones de
crisis por ejemplo un rescate y una
misión de evacuación o una operación de
estabilización en un entorno hostil
borrador de strategy comparte la unión
europea evidentemente lo plantea como
objetivo porque la unión europea es
consciente de que hoy por hoy sus países
europeos no tienen esa capacidad el caso
es que por todas estas carencias cada
vez que se eleva la atención en el este
de europa como por ejemplo ocurrió tras
la invasión y posterior anexión de
crimea por parte de rusia eeuu se ve
obligado a mover ficha y reforzar su
presencia en el continente la potencia
norteamericana es uno de los pocos
miembros tal vez junto al reino unido- y
quizás francia que puede realizar
despliegues muy rápidos de hecho los
países europeos tienen unas capacidades
tan limitadas que por sí mismos sin un
apoyo y la asistencia norteamericana es
muy probable que no pudieran garantizar
por sí mismos la propia seguridad de
todos los países miembros tanto es así
que la de barack obama creó en 2014 la
iniciativa de defensa europea conocida
como eddie por sus siglas en inglés
[Música]
iniciativa respondía a un viejo reclamo
de los países de la europa del este- con
ella se quiso reforzar la contribución
norteamericana a la seguridad europea
para lograr este objetivo la iniciativa
planteaba incrementar las fuerzas
desplegadas en países considerados de
primera línea como estonia letonia
lituania polonia también aumentar el
presupuesto destinado a realizar
ejercicios militares multinacionales y
mejorar las infraestructuras claves para
la disuasión en la práctica el programa
le ha costado a los norteamericanos
cerca de 25 mil millones de dólares y
entre los años 2016 y 2021 toda una
muestra de compromiso por parte del tío
sam
gracias a la iniciativa de defensa
europea eeuu ha desplegado cazas f-15 y
f-16 en reino unido e italia y también
ha incrementado el número de tropas
desplegadas en polonia y en los países
bálticos ahora bien la pregunta es es
este refuerzo suficiente para proteger a
europa de una agresión externa pues sí y
no al mismo tiempo sí porque gracias a
estos despliegues cualquier agresión
pasa por poner en jaque a los propios
eeuu no sólo por la disuasión general
que supone de por sí el compromiso de
seguridad mutua sino también por tener
que atacar a efectivos norteamericanos y
eso es amigos son palabras mayores es lo
que podríamos llamar disuasión de no
retorno
pero por otro lado los expertos en
estrategia militar parecen tener algo
muy pero que muy claro las tres
repúblicas bálticas que además cuentan
con una importante minoría rusa entre su
población son el gran talón de aquiles
de la otra seamos claros de acuerdo a
los estudios y simulaciones realizadas
rusia podría alcanzar las capitales
bálticas allí en riga y vilnius en un
máximo de 60 días es decir y ojo porque
esta es una cuestión vital en el debate
del ejército europeo el discurso de
disuasión general que es capaz de
abanderar la otan es la única protección
real que en la práctica estos países
tienen contra una invasión o un ataque
de guerra híbrida eso es quizás lo que
expliquen noticias como esta escala es
primer ministro de estonia pide más
tropas de eeuu en los bálticos el reino
quedó se plantea duplicar la presencia
de tropas en estonia la pregunta es por
qué estonia le pide a eeuu y al reino
unido más tropas y no hace lo mismo con
países europeos aliados que están mucho
más cerca
[Música]
pues básicamente lo hacen por una
cuestión de capacidad y disuasión al
final el gran activo que tiene la otan y
que por ejemplo nunca tendría una
organización de seguridad estrictamente
de la unión europea es que detrás de
ella está eeuu y en menor medida también
reinó unido- la mayor y una de las
mayores potencias militares del mundo
tampoco tendría esta misma organización
las capacidades de combate y despliegue
rápido que ahora los eeuu le aportan a
la otan y esto es algo que nos lleva
directamente a otro de los grandes temas
hasta como todos sabéis en la otan
existe una directriz de gastón defensa
del 2% del pib sin embargo salvo eeuu el
reino unido las repúblicas bálticas
polonia y alguna que otra excepción la
inmensa mayor parte de los miembros del
club atlántico no cumplen esa directriz
y la pregunta es estarían dispuestos a
cambiar su asignación de fondos públicos
e incrementar sus presupuestos militares
pues visto lo visto todo parece apuntar
a que no
[Música]
y ojo porque no se trata sólo del
volumen de gasto sino también muy
importante de su composición de la
composición del gasto por ejemplo
actualmente los países europeos de la
otan gastan en defensa prácticamente lo
mismo que china y mucho muchísimo más
que rusia el problema no es el volumen
de gasto sino sobre todo su composición
por ejemplo gastar mucho en personal y
poco en equipos de esta forma mientras
que por ejemplo en eeuu se destina el 30
por ciento de su presupuesto militar a
inversión en nuevos equipos y
tecnologías en el caso de los ejércitos
europeos esa cifra es mucho más baja la
media de los últimos seis años no llega
al 20 por ciento en definitiva que hoy
por hoy los ejércitos de los países de
la unión europea salvo alguna honrosa
excepción no tienen capacidad por sí
mismos para ser considerados como un
actor relevante incluso si los
analizamos de forma conjunta
[Aplausos]
y claro sin unas fuerzas armadas
efectivas y sin ser capaces de
garantizar ni siquiera la seguridad en
la europa continental como demonios vas
a ser capaz de tener una política de
seguridad totalmente independiente
cuando vas a establecer un discurso
disuasorio eficaz y de otras cuestiones
como la dependencia energética ya ni
hablemos ahora bien solucionarían todos
estos problemas la creación de una
estructura militar de defensa
estrictamente europea como parece
plantear macro no tiene acaso la culpa
la otan del poco compromiso manifestado
por muchos de sus países miembros estas
son las preguntas clave en toda esta
historia atentos
[Música]
la ilusión de la autodefensa
vamos a ver por qué macrón pide que
europa vaya por libre necesita realmente
la unión europea' avanzar en estructuras
militares aparte de la otan estaría
acaso mejor defendida europa si sólo
dependiera de sus propios recursos
prescindiera de los estados unidos pues
veréis en este caso la respuesta suelen
tener casi siempre un corte político
[Música]
la presidencia de donald trump en eeuu
por ejemplo fue de hecho gasolina para
el sentimiento de querer apostar el
futuro de la seguridad a unas auténticas
fuerzas armadas europeas porque bueno
digamos que trump no fue el tipo más
amistoso con la otan y los países
europeos han discutido sacar a eeuu de
la otan según asesores en medio de
nuevas preocupaciones sobre rusia no
está bien que se aprovechen en la otan y
luego que se aprovechen en el comercio y
eso es lo que sucede no podemos permitir
que eso suceda
donald trump no queremos ser más los
tontos estamos reduciendo las fuerzas
porque ellos no están pagando sus
facturas es muy simple donald trump si
eeuu retirará alrededor de 12.000
soldados de alemania pero casi la mitad
se quedarán en europa al final nada de
esto sucedió pero las palabras rara vez
son neutrales sea como sea la idea de
poner en marcha un ejército europeo una
estructura de coordinación decisión y
operaciones sin eeuu reino unido y
canadá no es algo nuevo pero gracias a
trump y quizás a la creciente
dependencia energética de rusia sí que
nos hemos encontrado con un nuevo fervor
claro que sobre todo esto ya se han
producido muchos intentos y muchos
fracasos de la unión europea nunca se ha
conseguido que las cosas funcionen bien
[Música]
ahí tenemos por ejemplo el caso de los
eurocorps que con hasta 60 mil efectivos
y 11 estados participantes son un cuerpo
militar establecido en 1992 y sirve
fundamentalmente de apoyo para misiones
de paz o de estabilización de la onu la
otan y la osce también hay otros
ejemplos como la fuerza de gendarmería
europea que es una especie de policía
europea con estatus militar y que apenas
cuenta con unas 2.000 unidades adscritas
por la fuerza operativa rápida europea
que desde 2012 ya no existe y que se
suponía iba a ser una pequeña fuerza de
despliegue rápido capaz de maniobra de
menos de cinco días para contribuir a
misiones humanitarias o misiones de paz
hoy todos estos cuerpos y alguno más
adicional están enmarcados dentro de la
cooperación permanente estructurada
conocida como pesco que busca la
integración estructural de las fuerzas
armadas de los 25 estados miembros que
están adscritos
podría cambiar esta realidad en el
futuro pues podría ser pero los primeros
en desconfiar de toda esta historia son
los países centro y el este de europa
los antiguos miembros del pacto de
varsovia países como polonia las
repúblicas bálticas rumanía bulgaria o
eslovaquia se sienten mucho más seguros
con washington que con bruselas a todos
los niveles
la crisis con ucrania ha sido un buen
ejemplo de ello mientras parís y berlín
querían desarrollar negociaciones
propias con putin la mayoría de países
del este de europa pedían dos cosas una
voz única conjunta de la otan y un mayor
despliegue de tropas de eeuu es muy
importante que la otan dé una respuesta
común a la tensión actual general ramón
a andrey jefe del estado mayor de las
fuerzas hermanas de polonia de hecho
esto podría ser un importante elemento
de fractura una grieta más sin francia y
alemania- siguieran empecinados en ir
por libre claro que los recientes
acontecimientos con rusia parecen haber
conseguido todo lo contrario a lo
pretendido por macrón y también por
vladimir putin
[Música]
la crisis en ucrania ha rejuvenecido a
la organización del tratado del
atlántico norte en cya podido mostrar su
importancia a décadas no ocurría además
mejorar la coordinación y la
interoperabilidad de los ejércitos
europeos es algo deseable pero intenta
desarrollar una estructura que termine
rozando con la alianza atlántica puede
ser una idea terrible pero tenemos hasta
aquí turno para ti cómo crees que europa
estaría mejor defendida con un ejército
europeo o con la otan a través del
paraguas de washington deja nuestra
opinión aquí abajo en los comentarios y
recuerda si te ha gustado este vídeo no
olvides darle al botón de like y
suscribir te avisa al político un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]